welcome back before we say goodbye we
want to play a quick round up truth or
dare
and we have cassandra
oh bowser
hi cassandra how are you hey i'm doing
great how are you doing great so today
i've got a truth for the both of you
okay yes okay yes so like you know in
this world of colvin 19 and a lot of
people
are working from home
how many days a week
do you wear the same pajamas because if
i'm gonna be honest i wear my pajamas
like three four sometimes five days a
week
so yeah how many days are you wearing am
i am i by myself with the three four or
five times
okay
um so on days that i'm not going
anywhere um you know for christmas
willie and i got each other the same
pair of pajamas in the same color and
the same size true story we didn't even
know right in doubt you were that couple
yeah we were that couple it's a cash it
was on sale yeah
yeah it's a cashmere little hoodie
pajama number and i would wear that
every day of the week if i could you
understand that yeah well also you
cannot wash cashmere like that has to go
out to the dry cleaner you gotta hand
wash it that's my excuse right
um but i would say really like probably
um three
yeah minimum yeah
it's all an old sweatpants for me
and i wear them out until they get holes
in them like i'm that guy so i don't
know how many days in a row i wear them
but i wear them until they have to get
thrown away
i work those clothes hard
that's good though no ways
that's good does that answer a question
oh that was my question thank you so
much well thank you cassandra thank you
for choosing your to spend your time
with us we make this show for you so
take it with you
[Music]